i've got two sillier show-inspired
questions to start with here though
do you
make your bed do you not make your bed
or is that a mixture of the two
i make my bed every day
mine is a chaotic mixture of the two
i'll go weeks of like doing it doing it
every day perfectly and then there'll be
times where it doesn't happen and it but
it actually it hurts it hurts my soul
because i love a maid bed and coming
home to my bed but sometimes
i just don't get around to doing it i
never realized how much that approach
stresses me out until i watched it
all right second one here i want you to
tell me about your best birthday when i
turned 21 and we were shooting the wild
season one and we went to waiheke island
and went to beautiful wineries and it
was
the most perfect weather
it was perfect beautiful so amazing that
actually was one of my favorite
birthdays it wasn't my birthday but
yeah
um i think one of my favorite birthdays
is probably um
recently my 23rd
i'm counting now my 23rd when erin and i
went to
um
heyman island
that's it right hamilton island hamilton
hamilton island hotel time had like a
helicopter over the beach aaron
organized this whole thing it's like
this birthday surprise it was very
romantic and very luxurious and i'd
never done anything like that before so
it was just lots of laughs it was yeah
funny as
that sounds absolutely lovely all right
i'm very eager to dig into spoilers but
before we get there first for both of
you here so obviously in season two we
see your characters learning from the
experience they had in season one in
order to survive but what about you two
as actors is there anything you know you
learned while filming season one that
you were able to apply to your work in
season two that made things like you
know filming more physical moments or on
location bits a little easier kind of
like a tipper trick totally i mean i
don't even know if there's anything
concrete but just like
i don't know
waking up so early with the long drives
and the long days like i don't know just
kind of managing energy levels like i
felt like i was going in it was like my
first season at the sport and then we
came back for season two and i was like
oh yeah no like i've been around the
block a little bit i know how to like
manage myself and my energy yeah
yeah i would have to agree with that
that's so true
i'm gonna do it i'm putting up the
spoiler warning let's get into some some
specific scenes here the fir the first
one i wanted to focus on was the i love
you moment because like i feel like we
do see many you know i guess i have to
say cliche representations of the
someone says it and then someone doesn't
moment but this to me feels so true to
these two characters and their
experience so i guess first for you mio
what was kind of you know the driving
force that made you playing that moment
feel like that was the right time for
her to i guess in a sense let it slip
yeah so
i think you know we this at the
beginning of season two we see shelby as
the happiest we've ever seen her and in
that scene specifically that scene and
the reason why she felt like she needed
to say in that moment was because
it was this beautiful like kind of
juvenile
um
day they were having just chasing each
other and kissing and laughing and it
felt so pure and i think that is the
closest to heaven that shelby has ever
felt and been so i think that was the
perfect moment for her to kind of
come out with that um
but
yeah my damn heart all right so
to toss it to you because like tony's
reaction again it's like i feel like
usually we get moments like that where
someone just like flat out doesn't say
it but it's not quite like that it feels
like she does receive it honestly she
just doesn't say it back
so
what was it like i guess crafting that
reaction in a way that felt right and
true to her i mean it was just so
it's so heartbreaking i think
in terms of crafting it like
these two are just sort of thrown into
this journey and they're just like
loving being together and then i feel
like this really catches her off guard
and then
sort of the
the trigger comes back for her around
that word love and
um it was so heartbreaking going on that
journey with her of not feeling
deserving of love but also so rewarding
for me as an actor being able to bring
find a way to get tony into a place
where she does feel deserving of
shelby's love and that is it made it all
the more
rewarding they showed us a very good job
with character arcs in that respect and
the reason why i love it so much all
right i'm going back to you now mia for
the hair cutting scene so we kind of
like dug into the movie magic required
for the bald cap last time so what is
the movie magic necessary in order to
you know cut your hair during filming
but
i guess i guess also i'm kind of leaning
into the idea of like we see we see hair
cutting scenes done so often that it
does feel a little bit cliche but again
that is a moment where
like i it felt very true to her so
what was it about what she had just been
through that made her kind of you know
show those feelings in that particular
way versus anything else she could have
done on the island
yeah it's kind of um it's interesting i
it feels for me very um
similar to kind of like self-harm for
shelby
um because it's she's destructing that
image she she's um
literally chopping away and letting
things fall out of her it's interesting
because um
shame and guilt follow shelby a lot and
she feels those emotions a lot and she
feels tortured by those things a lot and
even when we see
you know shelby and tony together and
she's finally we see her like letting go
and
um giving in to to her queerness and her
life and her partner it's beautiful and
then when it creeps up in another way it
it pops itself up and she feels it
really deeply
and
the only way she feels she can like
escape from that is
literally escaping from who she is and a
lot of who she is
is has so much to do with her hair
because you know with the whole pageant
lifestyle back at home
so much of that is about having this
perfect you know hair and
to see her
feel like she needs to literally chop
that all off to feel like
she's been punished it's just so sad to
me it's so sad but i'm hoping that you
know we turn around and we see her
rocking it you know
if we do a season three or whatever in
the future shall we
i'm rooting for it i i believe
so all right with that in mind just to
make some i guess playful predictions
here so now that we know that the two
ensembles are coming together for each
of you which member of the twilight of
adam experiment do you think that your
character would benefit most from if
they got the opportunity to spend time
with them and learn more from them
i would probably say
um ivan for shelby someone who's really
like
just another queer person that she can
have in her corner that probably she
could have those conversations with
potentially and feel like there's more
of her and other in other people and
other genders um and sexual expressions
i think that would be comforting for her
to see
meet someone more people that are
similar to her
i mean i think tony could learn a lot
from
somebody like bo i feel like she would
learn a lot from somebody who is
clearly feels things really deeply and
has a really open heart and is really
grounded and
i think should
and maybe and maybe i don't know what
he'd learned from tony she's a bit of a
firecracker but
but possibly
these ideas i'm happy i asked the
question we're manifesting them i need
more i feel so greedy that's the binge
wall of season two and now i already
want more huge congratulations it is
excellent yet again
thank you so much
you